[Música]
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su programa
sobre la actualidad francesa en esta
edición hablaremos de los incendios que
han afectado buena parte del país a lo
largo de este verano veremos cómo se
lucha contra las llamas y también el
trabajo que han venido realizando los
bomberos voluntarios luego iremos a la
región de marsella porque allí varios
scouts trabajan en la prevención de
incendios y terminaremos en el macizo de
mou para ver cómo después de las llamas
la naturaleza retorna a la vida
ah
[Música]
las fuertes temperaturas y las sequías
son las condiciones ideales para que se
multipliquen los incendios forestales en
lo corrido de este año ya son 60.000
hectáreas de tierra en las que se han
quemado en todo el país ante la
virulencia de las llamas se emplean todo
tipo de métodos para poderlas contener
veamos en el siguiente reportaje en qué
consiste combatir el fuego con el fuego
provocar un incendio para contener otro
a unos kilómetros de la localidad de jos
tense estos bomberos de arde se prenden
en llamas del borde de las vías con un
soplete que están creando un fuego
técnico a base de dos combustibles
y ya salen de esas
300 hectáreas quemadas por los propios
bomberos en gijón son fuegos que se
extinguen rápido y sirven para contener
el incendio en curso
quemamos vegetación para eliminar el
combustible para que cuando llegue el
incendio se apague por sí solo
a unos kilómetros de ahí se llevan a
cabo estas técnicas de prevención en la
autopista a 63 cerrada
son digamos
la tala de árboles otro método para
frenar el incendio decenas de árboles
son cortados a lo largo de la autopista
el objetivo es evitar que el fuego salta
de un lado al otro de la vía frank sage
ha trabajado desde las 4 de la mañana
quitando troncos y ramas las
cosechadoras forestales estaban aquí
esta mañana un poco por toda esta zona
talaron los árboles y nosotros movemos
todo eso hacia allá para que no se queme
esta parte los agentes forestales siguen
despejando la zona continuaremos la tala
a lo largo de la autopista hacia el
norte en verín verge hasta la vía de 110
que es la vía de lugo esta operación de
tala de árboles se extenderá durante
todo el día el trabajo de los bomberos
voluntarios ha sido pieza clave a lo
largo de toda esta situación algunos son
ingenieros profesores o artesanos y van
allí donde se solicita su ayuda en
francia hay 190 mil hombres y mujeres
capacitados para trabajar hombro a
hombro con los bomberos profesionales
como lo veremos en el siguiente
reportaje
llegaron para ayudarle a sus colegas de
la dejo
todos estos bomberos de los alves
marítimos son voluntarios que salieron
en la mitad de la noche hace dos días
con 31 años este ingeniero de profesión
dejó atrás a su mujer y a sus cuatro
hijos
no no paramos también tenemos nuestra
vida entonces es intenso el don de sí
mismo es una profesión que empezó pronto
para él con el de maría en su caso es
una historia de familia
mi padre era bombero voluntario en la
comuna donde vivíamos cuando yo tenía 10
años durante los fines de semana que él
estaba de guardia como yo estaba en el
colegio toda la semana para pasar tiempo
con él iba a darles una mano limpiando
las mangueras los camiones y todo eso y
hubo de camión
desde hace 38 años esa pasión no lo ha
abandonado las ganas de ser útiles son
el punto en común entre estos hombres y
mujeres que trabajan muy duro todos los
días aquí los soldados del fuego de los
eeuu fueron movilizados esta mañana para
regar los lindes para ayudar a las
personas para estar aquí cuando las
personas nos necesiten en fuga
y para ayudar a controlar los incendios
hace unos años florian trabajaba en el
sector de transporte
aprobó su examen profesional en abril
ya no le encontraba sentido a lo que
hacía y ser bombero me parece
gratificante satisfactorio quiere ser
profesional
y a vivir espero lograrlo actualmente
los cuarteles necesitan más manos tan
sólo en los ejes se necesitarían 150
bomberos adicionales con perfiles de
todas las áreas realmente es la
aglomeración de personas distintas
artesanos jefes de empresa o como hoy
agricultores estudiantes lo que hace que
podamos construir un equipo y brindar
ayuda para cubrir las necesidades habría
que reclutar 50.000 bomberos voluntarios
y aquí a 2027 los jóvenes también pueden
ayudar a prevenir los incendios eso es
lo que hace un grupo de scouts en la
región de marsella ellos están allí
vigilando los bosques al asecho de todo
conato de incendio veamos el siguiente
informe con los binoculares fijos en el
macizo estos jóvenes scouts vigilan
desde su atalaya el parque nacional
calanques de marsella reportan todas las
anomalías como un vehículo no autorizado
solo una colilla tirada por un visitante
o incluso un comienzo de incendio en
caso de un incendio hay que reportar se
lo muestra subiendo o si ya es una nube
y el color si es blanco o negro gris o
rojizo a mi me gusta mucho porque con
todo este material con los equipos con
los bomberos uno se siente profesional
se siente realmente útil los jóvenes
tienen entre 14 y 17 años llegaron de
todas partes de francia todos los días
salen cientos a patrullar y alertan al
puesto de mando en caso de necesidad
se ha detectado humo
hay que avisar a los bomberos navales
y vamos a controlar el cambio
[Música]
se trata de un ejercicio para los scouts
saben que hay que vigilar este parque
este patrimonio son conscientes de eso a
fin de cuentas les estamos dando una
formación sobre las distintas
herramientas que deben utilizar y
después de eso les toca a ellos
para los bomberos navales de marsella es
muy valioso el apoyo que brindan los
scouts cada verano desde hace más de 40
años
el objetivo es reportar muy pronto al
centro operacional lo que pueda parecer
un comienzo de incendio para que podamos
reaccionar e iniciar las acciones de
lucha bien dimensionadas para mantener
el comienzo de los incendios en las
superficies más pequeñas posibles este
verano las intervenciones de los
bomberos navales por incendios de
vegetación se redujeron un 20 por ciento
respecto al año pasado en parte el
mérito es de los scouts que también
hacen prevenciones cotidianas con los
visitantes del parque después de las
llamas cómo se recupera la vegetación es
cierto que habrá que esperar varias
décadas antes de que los bosques vuelvan
a restaurarse vamos a ir al macizo de
madoff porque allí hubo un terrible
incendio hace un año que acabó con siete
mil hectáreas de tierra y sin embargo la
naturaleza ha ido recuperándose poco a
poco
miles de pinos ennegrecidos calcinados
un año después del incendio de golf
aaron la naturaleza aún no ha retomado
su curso en el macizo de moja yo el
técnico forestal ha venido a comprobar
los estragos estos pinos están
totalmente muertos ya no tienen espinas
y si tienen espinas son rojizas ya no
están vivas y desde el año pasado no han
aportado nuevas espinas entonces no hay
ninguna esperanza de que los pinos
vuelvan a dar una población forestal el
16 de agosto de 2021 una colilla de
cigarrillo desató este incendio forestal
el más destructor en la región en los
últimos 15 años hubo tres muertos y más
de siete mil hectáreas de vegetación
quemadas pero algunos árboles están
adaptados en los incendios estos pinos
por ejemplo pueden contar con sus piñas
resistentes al fuego hasta cierta
temperatura los conos permanecen
cerrados y protegen las semillas en
tiempos normales las semillas caen al
suelo germinan y terminan por
reconstruir un bosque pero este año joel
pagán está preocupado los usa
preocupación ahora es que con este año
2020 particularmente seco hay tanto
déficit de agua y los suelos están tan
secos que la regeneración tendrá
problemas para mantenerse es un
guaguancó animal a sastre le preocupan
la sequía y la frecuencia de los
incendios cada vez más recurrentes y
forget home to count on se necesita
mínimo 30 ó 40 años para que la
vegetación forestal pueda regenerarse si
no el bosque se degrada hasta hacer un
matorral según radiografía machine
hay que sembrar nuevos árboles para
evitar ese paisaje por ahora no según
remy mont y el también técnico forestal
no necesariamente nos oponemos a
resembrar el problema de una siembra es
tener árboles que necesitan agua sabemos
que tendremos cada vez menos que habrá
cada vez más sequías entonces por ahora
en todo caso la mejor opción es confiar
en la naturaleza confianza a la lazio
aun le está en algunos sitios la
naturaleza le da razones para ser
optimista por ejemplo estos alcornoques
mediterráneos han resistido el incendio
y en el suelo los rebrotes alcanzan casi
un metro hasta aquí esta edición de
francia enfocó gracias por habernos
acompañado continúen con nuestra
programación en france 24 y france24
puntocom